hey everyone welcome to Simply learns
YouTube channel today we take you to The
Cutting Edge world of AI in 2024 in this
tutorial video we will unveil the top
languages for AI your gateway to the
dynamic world of artificial intelligence
AI continues to redefine Industries and
create groundbreaking Innovations to
harness its full potential you need to
know which program languages are the
stearing in the AI Revolution we will
dive deep into python R Julia and much
more uncovering their unique strengths
and weaknesses for programming in AI
whether you are an AI professional or a
curious learner this video will
illuminate the language landscape that
drives Innovation and transforms
possibilities join us in the unlocking
of the language of innovation before we
get started if these are the type of
videos you'd like to watch then like
share and hit that subscribe button and
the bell icon to get notified if you are
a professional with minimum one year of
experience and an aspiring artificial
intelligence professional looking for
online training and certifications from
the prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts
simply learns post-graduate program in
artificial intelligence from P
University in collaboration with IBM is
just what you need for more details head
straight to our homepage and search for
artificial intelligence postgraduate
program from F University or simply
click on the link in the description box
below now without further Ado let's go
to our training we will get started by
discussing about python followed by that
we will get into our programming
language then we have Julia followed by
that we have Java programming language
and lastly we have JavaScript so let's
get started with python python stands
out as the preferred language for AI
programming due to its verality
extensive libraries like tensive flow P
Toge and its userfriendly syntax it
streamlines development offers faster
prototyping and easy integration with AI
Frameworks Python's Rich ecosystem
enables data manipulation model
development and deployment despite its
interpreted nature it performs
efficiently in AI tasks however there
are few pros and cons to consider let's
get ahead with Pros so the pros of using
python for AI are vast Library support
python boasts a wealth of AI libraries
simplifying complex tasks next is
community and documentation its large
community ensures support and Rich
documentation followed by that we have
readability Python's clean syntax
enhances code readability and
collaboration after that we have
crossplatform compatibility code written
in Python runs seamlessly across
platforms lastly rapid prototyping
Python's Dynamic typing and ease of use
enable quick experimentation now that we
have discussed the pros of using python
let's look at few cons of using python
firstly slower execution python can be
slower than low-level languages due to
its interpreted nature next is global
interpreter lock or also called as G
G hampers multi-threaded performance
next resource intensive it may not be
able to be the best choice for resource
intensive AI applications followed by
that limited Mobile support not ideal
for mobile AI app development lastly
lack of low-level control for highly
optimized AI Solutions a lower level
language may be preferable now that we
have discussed python let's move ahead
and learn about our program programming
language R is a compelling choice for AI
programming due to its strengths in data
analysis and visualization crucial
aspects of AI development is also one of
the biggest reasons its extensive
ecosystem of packages such as carrot and
tensor flow provides comprehensive tools
for machine learning ours statistical
capabilities are invaluable in AI model
interpretation making it a go-to
language for researchers and data
scientists now let's proceed and discuss
the pro of using R for AI first is data
analysis RS data manipulation libraries
like
dplr and tiders are powerful for
processing AI data sets next
visualization with ggplot and ggplot 2
are excels at creating insightful data
visualizations crucial for understanding
AI model outputs next ahead we have
statistical rigor our St statistical
functions enhance the interpretability
of AI models moving ahead we have large
community a thriving R Community ensures
abundant resources and support lastly
integration our interfaces seamlessly
with AI Frameworks like tsor flow caras
and
h2o.ai now that we have discussed the
pros of this particular programming
language let's also consider some of the
common cons of using R for AI firstly
performance
R can be slower for large scale data
processing compared to languages like
python niche in AI is a second Point
while it's strong in data science R has
a more specialized role in the broader
AI landscape next ahead we have limited
deployment deployment of AI models
developed in R can be more challenging
than in some other languages next less
versatility R might not be the best
choice for task Beyond Ai and data
science lastly learning curve for those
who are new to programming Arts syntax
and Concepts can be initially complex
moving ahead we have Julia Julia stands
out as the excellent choice for AI
programming du to it speed versatility
and simplicity it's just in time or also
known as jit compilation accelerates
code execution making it exceptionally
fast for numerical and data intensive
tasks a crucial aspect of AI Julia
seamlessly integrates with popular AI
libraries offers native support for
distributed computing and is user
friendly now let us consider pros and
cons of Julia starting with Pros first
one is high performance Julia speed is a
game changer for computationally
demanding AI tasks next ecosystem it
provides access to AI libraries like
flux. JL and ml J moving ahead we have
eause its syntax is approachable and
resembles python making it more
accessible to developers next ahead we
have parallel Computing Julia's built-in
support for parallelism AIDS AI model
training and lastly open source being
open source encourages Community
Development and collaboration now moving
ahead we will consider some of the cons
of Julia firstly less mature ecosystem
while growing Julia's AI Library
ecosystem is not as extensive as
Python's next learning curve despite its
similarities to python adopting Julia
may require some adjustment third one
market adoption python is the dominant
language in AI which can impact job
opportunities compared to Julia limited
general purpose use is the fourth one
Julia is primarily designed for
Technical and scientific Computing and
lastly documentation some libraries may
have less extensive documentation
compared to python Julia's unique
combination of speed Simplicity and
extensibility make it a compelling
choice for AI programming especially for
applications where performance is
critical however it's essential to weigh
the pros and cons in the context of your
specific AI project and the broader
industry landscape moving ahead we have
Java Java is a solid choice for AI
programming due to its versatility and
reliability it offers a wealth of
libraries including deep learning 4J and
W making it suitable for machine
learning and AI development its
probability ensures AI applications can
run on various platforms seamlessly now
let's look at the proofs of using Java
for AI starting with crossplatform
compatibility Javas right ones Run
Anywhere philosophy ensures AI
applications work on different platforms
next we have strong ecosystem a rich
ecosystem of libraries simplifies AI
development next in the list is robust
and secure Java's inherent safety and
robustness are essential for ai's
critical applications then we have
Community Support a large developer
Community provides resources and support
lastly scalability Java's scalability
suits AI projects from small application
this is very crucial next ahead we have
the cons of using Java for AI firstly
performance Java can be slower than
languages like python or C++ for certain
AI applications and computations next
verbo syntax Javas code can be more
verbos increasing development time next
ahead is steep learning curve a strict
type system can be challenging for the
beginners in AI programming next is
resource consumption Java applications
might consume more memory lastly less
popular in research Java is less common
than python in AI research and
prototyping now comes the last
programming language of today's session
which is the JavaScript JavaScript is a
versatile choice for AI programming due
to its widespread adoption and
accessibility it can be it can be used
both on the client and server sites
making it ideal for developing AI
powered web application ations
JavaScript offers an extensive ecosystem
of libraries and Frameworks such as
tensor flow brain JS and synaptic
enabling seamless integration of AI
functionalities it supports for
asynchronous programming suits AI tasks
that involve data processing and
realtime interactions however JavaScript
isn't typically the first choice for
complex AI models due to the performance
limitations and lack of specialized AI
libraries nonetheless its broad utility
makes it an accessible entry point for
AI development now proceeding ahead we
will discuss the pros and cons of using
JavaScript for AI versatility JavaScript
can run on both the client and ser sites
making it suitable for webbased AI
applications next is extensive ecosystem
JavaScript has AI libraries like
tensorflow.js simplifying AI model
development third one is asynchronous
programming it supports asynchronous
operations for real-time processing next
accessibility a widely used and well
supported one with an abundance of
resources and Community knowledge is the
most important point of JavaScript pros
and lastly we have crossplatform
compatibility Works across different
platforms and browsers facilitating
deployment and now let's move ahead and
discuss the cons of this particular
programming language for AI programming
first one is performance limitations
JavaScript is generally slower than
lowlevel languages for compute intensive
AI tasks lack of specialized libraries
is the second one as it lacks some
specialized AI libraries and tools
available for languages like python next
is limited for complex models not ideal
for highly complex AI models due to
Performance constraints fourth one is
garbage collection overheads automatic
garbage collection can introduce latency
in real-time AI applications and lastly
debugging challenges debugging
JavaScript based AI code can be complex
especially in large scale projects those
were the important pros and cons of
using JavaScript for AI programming and
with that we have reached to the end of
this session on top languages for AI in
2024 should you need any assistance PPT
or other resources used in this session
please let us know in the comments
section below and our team of experts
we'll be happy to help you as soon as
possible until next time thank you and
keep learning stay tuned for more from
Simply Lear staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domain
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here